What do you think, if the stupid people resist any more
, let them be punished
Are you serious?
Hand them over and clap your hands
[music
] We're all in different positions
If we go help someone, the
rest of us will get hurt
What the
hell are we going to do?
If you take advantage of that opportunity,
if you use magic, the two of you will be known to be spirits.Then you
won't be able to spend your time freely in the city anymore
.  Something about
the magic test just now
Fireball No,
I think I added something
to it I have no choice but to give it a try.
Fireball
Multi-Shot
This is a special skill of the bereaved spirits that
allows you to use multiple spells of one continuous chant at the same time.